[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires voici les
titres de l'actualité de cette édition
centres commerciaux ouvertures ou
fermetures qu'en est il nous tenterons
de vous éclairer avec via moselle tv sur
les nouvelles règles en vigueur
actuellement des chiens dressés à
détecter le qu'ovide visite en gironde
grâce à tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest du centre de formation de nos
meilleurs amis vous allez le voir
soulager vos douleurs grâce à un
bracelet reportage de télégrenoble sur
un simulateur d'endorphines
révolutionnaire qui veut conquérir le
monde
enfin naissance de cinq bébés requins
ils sont nés au centre national de la
mer et c'est le carnet rose de cette
nouvelle année nous irons à la rencontre
de bébés requins née pendant la crise
sanitaire à boulogne sur mer grâce à wéo
la chaîne de la voix du nord on commence
ce journal avec les nouveaux dispositifs
pour freiner la propagation du coffee de
19 et de ces variants le premier
ministre a annoncé vous le savez la
fermeture des centres commerciaux non
alimentaire d'une surface supérieure à
vingt mille mètres carrés en moselle
d'ailleurs c'est la douche froide pour
une dizaine de centres et de boutiques
qui n'auront cette fois pas la
possibilité de faire le click and
collect les explications de fanny
bragard pour moselle télévision l'image
est rare le parking géant du meuble
complètement désert et des clients
surpris qu'ils trouvent porte close
san identique à farébersviller devant
les 55 mille mètres carrés du centre
commercial best ou les annonces de jean
castex ont pris tout le monde de court
les centres commerciaux non alimentaire
d'une surface supérieure à vingt mille
mètres carrés seront fermés une mesure
difficile à digérer pour des commerçants
déjà dans le rouge et qui depuis le
déconfinement redoublent d'efforts pour
s'adapter au protocole sanitaire ouvre
on ferme pour nous comme pour nos
commerçants
c'est extrêmement 10 de ceux projetés et
surtout un petit peu de concertation
vous voyez au final on nous a fait
décaler les soldes donc on a perdu
finalement deux semaines de soldes est
derrière nous confiait alors qu'ils en
avaient laissé les soldes à leur forme
originelle mais peut-être que du coup
on aura peut-être moins de stock dans
les boutiques à ce moment là d'autant
plus que cette fermeture est plus
drastique que les précédentes où en plus
de l'hypermarché quelques boutiques
pouvons encore travailler des
compliments click and collect ça
rapporte et pour certains commerçants 25
composantes chiffre d'affaires la vente
à emporter pour les restaurateurs c'est
également une somme de chiffre
d'affaires additionnel alors que la
maison de la presse par exemple les bap
auteurs les opticiens dans les centres
commerciaux n'ont pas le droit d'ouvrir
sans visibilité difficile pour ces
commerçants d'entrevoir le bout du
tunnel
à moins d'exercer à ciel ouvert car pour
l'heure les parcs d'activités
commerciales comme le wales actisud
peuvent toujours accueillir des clients
c'était logique 1 au vu de la
configuration de l'espace ici mais oui
évidemment pour les commerçants c'est un
soulagement de pouvoir rester ouverts
après une année très compliquée voilà en
attendant les éventuelles nouvelles
mesures qui pourraient arriver pour les
500 salariés du site c'est une réelle
délivrance après déjà trois mois de
chômage partiel
ah bah oui ça fait toujours pas parce
que je j'ai peur de me retrouver en
compte ou encore des quatre murs comble
mois de mars alors qu'un nouveau
confinement semblait imminent les
clients présents dans les années ce
lundi se réjouit encore pouvoir faire du
shopping tout ferme
88 on va faire comment rejeté apple
stress on va dire pour limiter le
brassage de la population
la jauge de fréquentation a été revue à
la baisse pour les commerces de plus de
400 mètres carrés
ils ne pourront désormais accueillir
qu'un client pour dix mètres carrés
voilà alors que l'on redoutait un
confinement ce sont d'autres mesures
restrictives qui ont été annoncées pas
de voyage hors motifs impérieux en
dehors de l'union européenne des
contrôles renforcés pour faire respecter
le couvre-feu à 18h et surtout la
fermeture des galeries marchandes de
plus de 20 mille mètres carrés une
stricte application du décret est
observé vous allez le voir par la
préfète de la loire le couperet est
tombé
adrien bletterie pour t elle cette
télévision loire 7 des rideaux qui se
baisse des lumières qui s'éteignent et
des locaux qui se vident marie guillard
et gérante d'un salon de coiffure dans
la galerie marchande de mon dieu et son
incompréhension est totale
on comprends pas pourquoi certains
certains peuvent et d'autres n'ont
apparemment on compte aussi la globalité
même des entrepôts des choses comme ça
rien n'est clair et même nos directeurs
de centres sont perdus mais eux ils ont
dû attendre la dernière minute pour
savoir
et encore une fois je retombe toujours
sur la même chose mais l'inégalité en
fait c'est toujours la même chose après
avoir réaménagé son local pour respecter
les gestes barrières et la jauge
limitant le nombre de clients dans son
salon marie ne sait plus quoi faire
malgré tout les distances qu'on a pu les
mesures qu'on a pu mettre en place ça va
toujours pas donc on sait plus quoi
faire nous l'ont cru on s'est pris du
côté de la galerie marchande de centre 2
le constat est le même mais certains
gars de la motivation on reste très
motivé parce que la galerie va être
rénové il va faire de belles choses on à
l'arrivée de primark nos équipes sont
rapatriés sur le salon de l'hôtel de
ville donc du coup on va quand même
pouvoir bosser et on attend que ça se
passe
on reste très motivé d'autres auraient
espéré une jauge plus strictes plutôt
qu'une fermeture
quitte à accueillir moins de clients
voilà c'était une idée peut-être aussi
qui aurait été à creuser qui aurait
permis à beaucoup de commerces de
l'enseignent comme les nôtres de rester
ouvertes et dans deux semaines c'est la
saint valentin les commerçants avaient
déjà réalisé leurs commandes
cet horloger à les faire gonfler son
chiffre d'affaires les consommateurs eux
ont un avis plus partagés bah c'est un
petit peu normal parce que c'est un
endroit où serait il dû beaucoup plus de
monde pour diminuer le risque de
contamination je pense que c'est normal
de faire
les fermes et les commerçants doivent
prendre leur mal en patience car
aujourd'hui aucune date n'est fixée pour
la réouverture est désormais comme vous
le voyez sur ces images de benjamin
delmas de 7 à limoges plus question de
déjeuner avec ses copains pour éviter
les brassages et un risque accru de
contamination
la répartition se fait par classe dans
les cantines comme celle de beaune les
mines près de limoges le nombre de
services est passé à 2 pour optimiser la
distanciation sociale les équipes
disposent de quinze minutes pour le
nettoyage et la désinfection du
restaurant scolaire
à l'heure actuelle du coup entre deux
services nous avons du coup à appliquer
un désinfectant sur les tables attendant
le temps d'action et notamment aussi
apporté une aération permanente des t3
réfectoire lorsque les enfants ont
quitté les lieux on connaissait les
chiens détecteurs d'explosifs de drogue
ou encore de billets de banque
désormais cinq chiens du programme sino
cov sont capables de détecter lakovic 19
regardez ce reportage et ses
explications au coeur de leur centre de
formation
à libourne en gironde bénédicte 2 1 pour
tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest s'est
rendu sur place
regardez chiens pisteurs des sapeurs
pompiers de gironde maul qui est formé
depuis quatre semaines à la détection du
virus des entraînements quotidiens pour
le sensibiliser à l'odeur des molécules
du coc vie de 19
il y à un système de convenir de
l'action souffre et qui se fait sur les
cellules qui crée une odeur vraiment
particulière et non le but c'est de
créances et des chiens sur ce cocktail
droit les chiens il travaille sur une
ligne de d'icônes où on a un prélèvement
voire deux prélèvements de sources
odorantes qu'ovide plus ça en même temps
on a greffé aussi des compresses neutre
pour apprendre le chien à se fixer vie
relance la partie moléculaire dégagée
par ce cocktail ou d'oran des
prélèvements de sueur de patients
positifs au virus sont disposées au
milieu des échantillons négatifs
à terme les cinq chiens du programme
seront capables d'établir une
présélection de cas positifs évitant
ainsi un dépistage de masse quand vous
êtes enfin d'épidémie ou vous avez un
taux de prévalence qui est faible
si vous voulez tester toute une
population vous avez le coup de tester
toute une population pour trouver 2 % de
positif si on fait une présélection avec
des chiens qui ont démontré leur
capacité été validée vous allez tester
pour valider avec des tests de référence
ceux qui ont été marqués comme positif à
ce jour 95 % des prélèvements positifs
au kovy 19 sont détectés par les chiens
du programme voilà et puis sur le
terrain des mouvements sociaux dans les
territoires une quinzaine de tracteurs
sur le parking d'une grande surface de
contrexéville une nouvelle action coup
de poing des syndicats et des jeunes
agriculteurs
cette semaine alors que les négociations
commerciales annuelles entre industriels
et distributeurs ont commencé soulager
les douleurs c'est le pari que s'est
lancé une société de grenoble en 2016
cette entreprise qui compte 25 salariés
a conçu le premier simulateur
d'endorphines par ondes millimétriques
et sportifs savent ce que c'est
l'endorphine l'hormone du bien-être le
reportage de charlotte foltzer pour
télégrenoble sur place regarder soulager
les douleurs aiguës sans utiliser de
médicaments
c'est le pari que s'est lancé rémédi
labs créé en décembre 2016 l'entreprise
de 25 salariés a créé le premier
simulateur d'endorphines par ondes
millimétriques dans les andes
millimétriques c'est quoi c'est un
signal électronique de très haute
fréquence qui lorsqu'il est appliqué sur
une zone fortement énervé du corps va
envoyer un influx nerveux au cerveau et
libéré l'endorphine cérébrale et
l'endorphine cérébrale en fait celle
antalgiques du corps l'endorphine a donc
des vertus antalgiques mais peut
également avoir des effets très positifs
sur notre stress ou encore notre sommeil
la technologie rémi di aidera donc des
patients atteints de fibromyalgie de
migraine légumes ou encore d'arthrose de
manière non invasive sous forme de
bracelet une technologie développée avec
l'aide du cea leti et de st micro
électronique pour fonctionner notre
dispositif doit être placé sur une zone
qui est fortement une erreur d'où le
choix du poignet maintenant notre
patient quel qu'il soit utilisé ce
dispositif pendant une session d'une
demi heure et les bénéfices vont durer
pendant des périodes beaucoup plus
longues plusieurs heures encore une fois
c'est assez dépendant de la pathologie
dans le cadre de nos patients
fibromyalgiques on est sur une
utilisation quotidienne entre trois et
cinq fois par jour ce selon le le besoin
et l'envié du patient la douleur
chronique toucherait jusqu'à 20% de la
population mondiale
un marché important que vise
l'entreprise rémi di labs on est sur un
marché qui est absolument colossal et
donc nous apprêtons à préparer
l'entreprise en fait pour un
développement commercial absolument
mondiale en commençant par l'europe
alors la france bien sûr parce que nous
sommes français
les pays européens les états unis et
après une extension totalement
internationale la technologie de ré midi
l'ap ce n'est pas encore commercialisé
mais de nombreux essais cliniques sont
en cours notamment avec le chu de
grenoble le lancement de sa
commercialisation est prévue pour 2022
on prend maintenant la direction du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
tony estanguet le président du comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 est venu rencontrer
des jeunes là-bas dans le cadre de la
semaine olympique
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et de bischheim temeria 106 tebbane pour
tv soixante dix huit sur place l'ancien
champion de canoë tony estanguet s'est
mis au cyclisme le temps d'un après midi
le président du comité d'organisation de
paris 2024 était ce mercredi 3 février
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son objectif promouvoir le site retenu
pour les jo-2010 le cadre de la semaine
olympique
on est ravi de pouvoir partager ce
moment avec la génération de 1024 c'est
tellement important au delà des
compétitions d'engager d'entraîner avec
nous cette génération de leur donner
envie de découvrir ces sports de leur
donner envie de découvrir aussi des
athlètes
et voilà moi je remercie toutes celles
et ceux qui ont permis cette opération
cette semaine olympique et paralympique
à l'école parce que cette semaine on va
mobiliser 500 mille enfants qui un peu
partout sur le territoire vont être
mieux sensibilisés à l'importance de la
pratique sportive
cette semaine olympique a été lancé à
l'initiative de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports
cet après midi une centaine de lycéens
de saint quentin en yvelines a pu tester
le vtt et le bmx avec le triple médaillé
d'or aux jo ça fait plaisir de voir sur
quoi les futurs athlètes ils vont
travailler et c'est franchement ça fait
plaisir de voir un athlète de haut
niveau il faut quand même le resituer ça
dans un contexte historique que les jeux
en france et une fois tous les 100 ans
si on regarde derrière nous et que l'on
puisse associer le plus possible la
jeunesse à l'engouement que cela va
provoquer autour du sport
c'est à mon avis ce qu'il faut
absolument pas manquer dans la proche du
de ces jeux olympiques de 2024 la
semaine olympique se terminera ce
vendredi sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines avec la découverte
de la colline d'elancourt le site
recevra les épreuves de vtt en 2024
je vous le disais dans les titres à
boulogne-sur-mer carnet rose avec la
naissance de cinq bébés requins
il s'agit de bébé requin zèbre une note
positive en ce début d'année car c'est
rare
le centre national de la mer à la même
enseigne que les musées et toujours
malheureusement fermée au public
est ce déjà depuis plusieurs semaines un
manque à gagner qui fragilise la
situation financière de ce site où près
de 60 mille animaux doivent se faire
soigner caroline fichten nous présente
ces bébés requins et s'est rendu sur
place pour ueo la chaîne de la voix du
nord
c'est l'heure de la sieste pour ces deux
requins zèbres arrivé tout jeune il y a
dix ans à nausicaa ils sont devenus
parents il y a quelques semaines
c'est la première fois effectivement
qu'on a des naissances de requin zèbre
c'est c'est le fruit d'un travail de
longue patience
c'est ce qui fait la fragilité des
requins également sont des animaux qui
se reproduisent très lentement pour
découvrir les bébé requin zèbre c'est
dans les coulisses de nausicaa qu'il
faut aller ici deux fois par jour s'ils
m'ont nourri les trois premiers nés en
août les animaux mangent environ 30 g de
crustacés par jour soit la moitié de
leur poids et c'est grâce à cette pince
que les soigneurs nourrissent les
requins zèbres ont réalisé
une cible tout simplement pour les faire
venir
les animaux vont se retrouver dans des
volumes de plus en plus grands et c'est
important pour eux qu'ils aient un
repère pour qu'on puisse les les
alimenter correctement dans cette pièce
deux autres requin zèbre né fin décembre
grandissent tranquillement dans un plus
petit volume d'eau les six premiers mois
tout doit être rigoureux les soigneurs
de nausicaa sont vigilants car même si
l'aquarium est fermée au public
l'activité en coulisse n'est jamais à
l'arrêt nous avons cinquante huit mille
animaux à nausicaa et donc il nous faut
les accompagner au quotidien que ce soit
en termes de nourrissage ou en termes de
soi nous avons aussi des équipes
techniques qui ont besoin d'être ici la
maison ne ferme jamais en coulisses le
travail continue donc dans quelques
semaines ou quelques mois c'est requin
zèbre partiront vers d'autres aquariums
des requins zèbres peut être l'avez vous
remarqué qu'ils ont grandi sans père de
leurs rayures et deviennent acheter les
anglais les appelle d'ailleurs des
requins léopard et puis regardez ces
images qui nous ont été envoyées par
marion aussi de notre partenaire du
groupe la dépêche à l'union près de
toulouse une équipe de préhistoriens et
de plasticiens travail a créé la
réplique de la grotte cosquer cette
grotte ornée datant de la préhistoire
est victime de la montée des eaux près
de cassis elle est invisible du grand
public alors qu'elles présentent un
grand intérêt archéologique et c'est une
société toulousaine qui s'applique à
fabriquer 8 paroisse à partir de photos
et de modélisation 3d
un travail long et minutieux pour
reproduire la roche mais aussi les
gestes des artistes de l'époque
ces panneaux devraient prendre place
dans la vie la méditerranée sur le port
de marseille en 2022
on part pour evian maintenant avec nos
partenaires de la chaîne tnt sur place 8
mont blanc le bâtiment que vous allez
voir est le symbole de l'histoire
thermale de la cité lémanique
longtemps attendu les travaux de
restauration de la buvette cacha sur
place viennent de démarrer une deuxième
phase qui doit rendre au bâtiment une
jeunesse perdue depuis des années
c'est un reportage de jean paul crespy
sur place le chantier de restauration de
la buvette cacha vient de démarrer avec
l'installation en
assad et à l'intérieur du bâtiment d'un
imposant échafaudage une couverture de
type parapluie doit compléter l'ensemble
de la structure pour protéger la
restauration du clos couvert
c'est à dire la rénovation de la
charpente de la couverture et de la
zinguerie lors du démontage et de la
restauration de la toiture
cette étape charnière prévoit également
la rénovation des façades et la
restitution des éléments disparu c'est
l'emblème de la ville d'evian nantes il
fallait qu'on y travaille et c'est
vraiment le vrai début des travaux pour
nous puisque la première phase c'était
la mise en sécurité du des vitraux et là
c'est vraiment le début du chantier à
mener à bien ce chantier retrouver une
jeunesse perdue les travaux de
restauration seront conduits par des
entreprises rompu aux travaux de
restauration des monuments historiques
cette phase devrait durer 16 mois les
tranches suivantes seront consacrées
entre autres à la restitution de l'ale
du grand promenoir début du 20e siècle
c'est ici que tout se passait dans cette
halle où les gens qui venaient en cure
thermale venait passer se détendre ici
ils allaient prendre de l'eau est
ensuite ils venaient se détendre ici
c'est vraiment l'histoire d'evian ici
c'est tout à fait magique vous êtes dans
un autre monde
le coût global de cette première tranche
de travaux s'élève à plus de 4 millions
d'euros un coût important dû au
caractère unique de l'édifice et à la
complexité de la restauration dans le
cadre du plan de relance
le projet a bénéficié d'une subvention
complémentaire de 825 millions euros du
ministère de la culture
c'est le moment de la rubrique
écorégions dans ce gîte et des
territoires
bonjour michel picot bonjour cyril
bonjour à tous j'avais envie de vous
parler aujourd'hui de cette entreprise
familiale qui vient de fêter ses deux
cent vingt ans il s'agit de l'entreprise
de la famille peugeot dont les deux
frères aînés jean pierre et jean
frédéric avait transformé le moulin
familial dans le doubs en fonderie
d'acier tout va démarrer là nous sommes
alors au début du 19e siècle cette
fonderie va fabriquer alors des rubans
d'acier des six égoïne et même des
crinolines pour les robes de soirée et
en 1840 voilà le premier mot
à café viendront ensuite les moulins à
poivre et beaucoup d'autres objets
autour de l'acier est destiné notamment
à la cuisine mais la famille ne manque
pas d'idées et d'enviés de créer
certains membres feront des vélos les
vélos peugeot par exemple
armand peugeot s'intéressera à lui aux
automobiles en créant la marque au lion
ce logo est apparu lui en 1850 est il
utilisé par toutes les filiales de la
famille l'entreprise est toujours
implanté dans le doubs et la famille
c'est plutôt focalisés sur l'automobile
ces dernières années il faut bien le
dire mais elle est revenue en 2014 dans
le capital et l'activité de peugeot
saveur aujourd'hui la marque s'est
diversifiée avec par exemple ce moulin à
graines de lin ou encore ce verre à
whisky révolutionnaire la marque
française emploie 160 personnes elle est
labellisée entreprise du patrimoine
vivant
une belle histoire d'entreprises
familiales à l'heure où la marque
peugeot et notamment les voitures psa
fusionne avec fiat chrysler pour devenir
un poids lourd mondial de l'automobile
on parle maintenant dans ce grand jt des
territoires pour la bretagne
connaissez-vous l'enluminure c'est un
art médiéval qui est pratique et vous
allez voir par astrid
depuis 2005 elle s'est installée à
fougères depuis quelques mois un
reportage de justin baro pour tvr arènes
pouvoir se produire
le motif surtout vous preniez bien votre
temps tout l'après midi nathalie
propriétaire d'une pension canine à
fougères devient l'élève apprentis
d'astrid bertha ya longtemps que j'ai
envie
j'aime beaucoup tout ce qui est les
vitraux les habits tout ça j'essaye de
prendre du plaisir aux cheveux parce que
c'est très anxiogène pour noir et que
quand vide avec tout ce qu'on entend la
télé donc comme on dit je vais faire
quelques heures quelque chose que j'aime
je veux découvrir sur toi astrid bertin
et maître enlumineur depuis 2005 elle
est l'une des rares spécialistes de cet
art médiéval en france après un premier
atelier à avranches pendant douze ans
elle s'est installée à fougères depuis
le mois de novembre
j'ai découvert le milieu belge justement
au fond c'est la franche donc là où
étaient conservés les manuscrits
autrefois les travailler quatre étés de
suite on emploi saisonnier
mais à force de lire des livres pour
faire des visites guidées essayer de
faire des visites de plus en plus
complète
je me suis dit au projet apprennent à
faire à son atelier à trith bertin
réalise des copies d'enluminures
commandé par ses clients mais aussi des
créations plus modernes les demandes
viennent majoritairement de particuliers
mais elles viennent aussi de mairie pour
des charte de jumelage ou autres blaze
moi ce que j'aime dans l'atelier ici
c'est que j'ai pu en fait mener
le milieu du moyen âge avec des choses
si plus moderne je veux montrer au
public en fait que leur lit mineur est
un art vivant un lien entre le moyen âge
et du 21e siècle 1 aussitôt installé
aussitôt adopté l'atelier le parchemin
des limbes fera partie des lieux avoir
pendant les fêtes médiévales à fougères
astrid bertin espère y donner des cours
gratuits de calligraphie en costumes
d'époque et puis loin de la bretagne
regardez ces images la petite histoire
dans la grande la semaine dernière joe
biden à redécorer le bureau ovale de la
maison blanche
parmi les changements symbolique un
tableau de benjamin franklin un par le
carpentrassien duplessis une bonne
nouvelle pour carpentras qui n'a pas
oublié le peintre une exposition est
même en cours de préparation d'ici deux
ans là-bas sont des images qui nous ont
été envoyées par nos partenaires de la
provence sur place voilà nous partons du
côté des antilles dans ce grand jt des
territoires avec l'appropriation
culturelle ou hommage la question est
posée c'est à l'occasion de la fashion
week digital que la maison louis vuitton
a présenté le fashion film de sa
collection automne-hiver 2021 et les
silhouettes imaginées par le directeur
artistique américain virgile tableaux
font référence à des communautés
d'origines divers parmi les accessoires
un cabas en tissu madrague vous allez le
voir qu'a suscité la polémique sur les
réseaux sociaux et au sein de la
communauté antillaise certains crient à
l'appropriation culturelle d'autres
parlent de représentation de la
diversité
reportage de hélène sérignac pour atv
martinique sur place louis vuitton
saison automne hiver 2021
parmi les silhouettes constitué par le
directeur artistique
un petit détail n'a pas échappé à la
communauté antillaise un cabas à
l'effigié du madras créé la polémique
sur les réseaux certains criaient à
l'appropriation culturelle de la part de
cette maison de luxe
mais pour jean yves zamor consultant
mode il n'en est rien on devrait s'en
réjouir que noah arrive à la tête d'une
maison aussi importante aussi influente
dans le domaine du luxe
donc ces huit points quand même dans le
groupe l
bmh donc il n'ya pas d'appropriation
cultuelle parce que c'est un endroit
comme nous même qui a fait des
recherches pour comprendre un bain les
différentes histoires des différentes
diasporas qui sont présentes dans le
monde
il est d'origine il vient du ghana
verger la blu et je trouve je salue
cette prouesse artistique parce que il
aborde plusieurs plusieurs
problématiques racisme homophobie
mélange des gens mélangent des codes et
s'est amusé un message puissant et je
trouve très simpliste de s'arrêter a
juste un cabas il monte des choses en
effet et alors que les réactions sont
vives sur les réseaux sociaux dans les
rues de fort de france
le ressenti des passants concernant
cette création est plutôt apaisé j'ai vu
ça ce matin se logent les réseaux mais
je pense que c'est le mahb là à la base
ça vient d'inde aussi donc on cherche la
peau prix aussi mais je n'ai par kanu
donc je pense que c'est une polémique
qui n'est pas justifié c'est un tissu
oui on y donne à tous les martiniquais
un petit sac madras avec le 8 on met pas
de souci et s'il ne donne pas alors là
c'est parce c'est pas gentil là
appropriation culturel ou représentation
de la diversité
une chose est sûre l'utilisation de ce
tissu emblématique de notre histoire par
un des directeurs artistiques les plus
en vogue aura défrayé la chronique
et puis des images qui nous viennent de
monte-carlo grâce à monaco info dans ce
grand jt des territoires avec la récolte
des bigarade sont des oranges amères et
plusieurs quartiers de la principauté
sont concernés par cette récolte
sandrine maigre et omaha des housses se
sont intéressés au travail mené sous les
bigaradiers du quartier de la condamine
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
du grand jt des territoires sur vos
chaînes de télévision locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde avec la
participation de la presse quotidienne
régionale
merci de votre fidélité et à très vite à
voir
[Musique]